laury thilleman féministes ou pas faut
évidemment à tout jamais féministe ouais
j'ai une petite remarque assez
sympathique
à l'issue d'une dame enregistrement de
la première émission ski qui parlait de
ski sur eurosport ou je portais un
perfecto et à la fin de l'émission dit
c'était bien l'émission est par contre
le perfecto pourquoi fin ça fait par
appel au ski non je dis ouais mais en
fait toi quand tu présentes les
émissions de foot ou de rugby
on ne demande pas de porter le maillot
ton tout aux joueurs préférés pensé quoi
le délire en fait pourquoi nous femmes
on devrait être la représentante du
sport qu'on présente à l'antenne je
comprends pas la logique à il ya quand
même des codes de l'ancien temps de miss
france je dirais qu'ils frôlaient le
sexisme mais
mais on avance cette année d'ailleurs
l'émission portait sur les droits les
draps les droits des femmes à proprement
parler et notre belle maeva cook est je
crois une
une belle représentante de la cause
féminine en tout cas elle milite pour sa
est la paix dans le monde
là évidemment on parle toujours de ça
dans tous les médias tous les jours on
s'endort on pense à la paix dans le
monde
la paix dans le monde évidemment justin
chiffres comme ça 20% c'est le nombre de
femmes invitées dans les matinales radio
[Musique]
honnêtement mon rang par mois c'est
l'ignorance je pense que c'est donner
trop d'importance sinon aux personnes
qui qui nous attaque
je sais que c'est parfois pape enfin que
c'est pas simple pour certaines qui en
prennent vraiment plein la figure
mais en tout cas moi c'est mon rang pas
tous les jours
tous les jours les chats lisant
[Musique]